[Music]
like many Greek villages Morris is
mostly old they were preparing for a
funeral when we arrived but in this
village of 600 people they have other
worries than the dead in the hotel over
the railway line 400 refugees are being
housed it isn't going well the first
time I saw them I felt fear I saw faces
full of anger I could see them thinking
that I was safe in my house why are we
suffering is to keep my daughter's
bicycle outside but one of them tried to
take it they've got a nerve they don't
understand anything the other day the
villagers met and told the police they
were feeling unprotected and said they
were thinking about arming themselves
with guns against the refugees obviously
everyone has to do something and if we
don't have a weapon we'll find something
else at the hotel they know all about
this but it's not their main problem
there's a mental health crisis to
contend with I share the same took us to
the place where a few days ago an Afghan
man who'd been wrongly told his wife and
children had been moved somewhere else
without him hanged himself from a tree
the next day Hussein's friend riad
hanged himself inside the hotel
his entire family had been killed in
Iraq he complained his severe depression
was being ignored his funeral wasn't
quite so well attended as the one in the
village he told them what had happened
to his family they gave him an injection
and he was like a robot when he came
back he was saying everyday I'm not okay
I'm not okay and they did nothing for
him over the last few months the
incoming center-right Greek government
has scaled back medical and psychiatric
support for Refugees to prove to an
increasingly hostile public that it's on
their side here they can bandage their
feet
not their minds now a lot of people are
struggling not only about mental
healthcare also when they need an
operation that follow up after
operations x-rays seems like this or as
it's much more difficult to find a place
where the people get treatment the sad
truth is that the story of Morris is in
microcosm a reflection of how Europe has
failed to get on top of refugee
resettlements and to heal people even in
hospitable Greece these two groups of
people are worlds apart
Lawrence Lee al-jazeera Maurice northern
Greece